it's Disney night on dancing the Stars a
movie that we're doing is the Little
Mermaid I'm playing Ursula it's gonna be
hard for me to be a villain in this
dance because I'm really shy let's do
that again
one two three there you go
where's my god baby Sophia I came here
today to encourage Sophia I've known her
since she was a baby so you know what
it's like right you've done the shot I
wasn't on for very long look at the
rumba
did me under sophie is doing so good
although she's a little shy sometimes
there are so many big personalities in
this competition I really want to see
you turn it up I think my shyness really
hurt me so I really want you to be
confident you just have to like let it
go I feel a lot more confident that I
know that kid maad my back 1 2 3
[Applause]
I admit that in the past I've been a
nasty they weren't kidding when they
called me well a witch that you'll find
that nowadays I've mended all my ways
repentance in the night and made a
switch
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]